- Des dizaines de milliers
de messages sont en ligne.
Il y a eu agressions non
dénoncées, puis Me too.
- Stop the violence! Stop the
rape!
- L'été dernier, une autre vague
de dénonciations des violences
sexuelles déferlait sur
la toile. Depuis des années,
des victimes dénoncent
leur parcours douloureux
à travers le système
de justice.
- On m'a demandé de quelle
couleur les rideaux étaient
dans la pièce où je me suis
faite violer à 4 ans t'sais...
- Lily Thibeault a témoigné
dans le documentaire
"La parfaite victime".
LILY THIBEAULT, survivante
d'agression sexuelle
- Moi, je suis rendue à prendre
action pour que mes enfants,
pour que les enfants des autres,
ne vivent pas dans ce monde-là
que moi j'ai connu. Je veux que
les choses changent.
- Et le changement, pour elle,
passe par la création
d'un tribunal spécialisé
pour les crimes sexuels.
- Il y a beaucoup de choses
qu'on peut faire pour aider
les survivants, mais ça,
c'est absolument urgent.
VÉRONIQUE HIVON, députée PQ de
Joliette, membre du Comité
- C'est une instance dédiée
à l'intérieur de la chambre
criminelle de la Cour du Québec
pour ces crimes-là, avec
des gens formés, spécialisés,
un accompagnement dédié
et des aménagements dans
les manières de faire.
- Appuyée par la députée
Véronique Hivon, Lily Thibeault
lance aujourd'hui une pétition
pour que cette recommandation
phare du rapport d'experts
"Rebâtir la confiance", déposée
en décembre dernier, soit mise
en place rapidement.
- Moi, je pense que c'est
possible de mettre en place
un tribunal spécialisé au cours
de la prochaine année, avant
donc la prochaine élection,
s'il y a de la volonté...
- De la volonté, le ministre
Jolin-Barrette assure
qu'il y en a.
SIMON JOLIN-BARRETTE
ministre de la Justice, Québec
- Vous me connaissez, lorsque
j'en fais une priorité...
ça devient une priorité.
- Sans toutefois fournir
d'échéancier précis.
- L'objectif est de faire
en sorte de pouvoir mettre
en place un tribunal spécialisé
dans les meilleurs délais,
et c'est ce à quoi on travaille.
- Mais dans le monde juridique,
il existe une certaine
résistance.
- J'ai beaucoup d'hésitation
avec un tribunal spécialisé.
- Mieux accompagner les victimes
oui, mieux informer
les intervenants aussi,
mais ce que cette avocate
craint, ce sont les effets
pervers.
Me DANIÈLE ROY, VP, Asso. QC
des avocat.e.s de la défense
- J'ai effectivement peur
qu'on retrouve plus d'innocents
retrouvés coupables. Parce que
vous savez, écoutez, je suis
consciente que c'est pas
un discours qui est très
populaire en ce moment,
sauf qu'il est très important
qu'on ne le perde pas de vue.
- Selon le DPCP, l'an dernier,
plus de 70 % des dossiers
de violences sexuelles
ont mené à des accusations.
Ici Jacaudrey Charbonneau,
Radio-Canada, Mo